home alone jingle all the way die hard
yes die hard the great Christmas movies
are usually shown on Boxing Day not
Christmas Day the leftover meal that
your parents slaved over are eaten on
Boxing Day
not Christmas Day finishing off that
game of Monopoly that dad fell asleep
during on Christmas Day that happens on
Boxing Day the food coma and the
resulting lie in that's Boxing Day not
Christmas Day when mum wakes you up
early to come down and open presents and
you have to come down tired because you
spent the whole night wrapping presents
until 2:00 a.m. Boxing Day is integral
part of Christmas and if you're having
to leave home at 3 a.m. to open your
shop for the 5 a.m. sales you're not
experiencing any of it that's why we
need to keep shops closed on both
Christmas Day and Boxing Day it won't
damage the economy because we'll just
have Boxing Day sales on the 27th
instead and the workers will be happier
for it tis the season to be lazy so I
say boxing days in boxers but the
trouble is are half the high streets you
go down these days are closing down I
mean there's also shops closing down
it's full of they're full these days of
cafes and nail shops and you if you stop
retailers opening on Boxing Day you're
loaning quicken up
I think the decline of the highest fee
which is a very serious thing I mean I
actually think it played quite a part in
the elections you know if you you know I
mean I live in Richmond I'm Thames which
is quite rich area most of the shops all
closing down if go to some of the more
deprived parts of Goodman there's hardly
anything in the high spec therefore
you've got to actually try to allow we
try to get shops to be more affluent to
give them going to get them and I don't
think closing them down on boxer does
gonna help putting it on the next day
after isn't gonna change I'm half the
sales of if you go around I mean I was
up in Covent Garden in London yesterday
half the sales are going they were
already on this it there's a shop called
home bargains which I'm sure a lot of
people watching will have heard of
and a complete and utter addicts turn
buggers and it was back I called a
business I called Tom Morris and what
he's doing this year he's giving all his
22,000 employees the day off paid day
off he's not taking that there then and
you know yeah rock today and he's not
taking it out of there and he will leave
and so bearing in mind that Boxing Day
is the busiest trading day of the if
everyone did what Tom Morris is doing
then the next date would have become the
business day just just by all rights
wouldn't it and it would just it would
just happen naturally this is what home
bargains say Cal to house staff thank
you for all your hard work once again
this year all of our stores will be
closed on Boxing Day to ensure you're
able to spend time with your friends and
family and to our customers all of our
stores will be closed on Boxing Day this
year to ensure all our hard-working
staff are able to enjoy the Christmas
break don't I think I think you're right
on both accounts but I think and I
really do feel sorry for retail stuff
find enough accountable where I was I
was in a shop one day this week and all
the Christmas hours were there and these
poor souls will get one day off and as
you rightly say that means for some of
them up at five six whatever it might be
so you are right
the staffed but actually Greg is right
as well because of the impact and and I
think you're right i think the general
malaise and is it really surprising in
the general election that so many towns
in the north and the midlands voted
conservatives with the photic instead
with their high streets posing that
concerns that they have a leak on and i
think you're right sir actually you're
on both counts and it would be great but
I don't think they can afford it it's
not modern it isn't actually the biggest
day of the year because it's apparently
10% more people shop on Black Friday
than Boxing Day can I mention the other
lots of groups of people I think it's
fair to say that you know lots of people
not just retail workers have to work can
I just make you know care workers nurses
nurse chefs polices police security
kitchen catering medical kerchief senior
co-workers you know it's not just
retailers fast our farm workers midwives
and I'm pleased that you know lots of
the big retailers are leading the charge
little Aldi among and M&S are also along
with him bothering the dáil 100,000
people have apparently signed a petition
supporting what you say is it
they everyone should get a day off who
would be pressure on staff can't do that
staff will be told that if you're
offered time and a half a double time
you would take it yeah also your boss is
gonna say to you if you don't work we
might not you might not have a job by
this time next year so then be pressure
on people to work on Boxing Day I'm just
impressed to see that you're agreeing
with me in sports in a four four-day
week you see that statistic there's a
very well-known very large store in
Knightsbridge in West in London which I
think we all know and under the day of
the first day of their sale they've
worked out if there a minute late
opening they lose a million quid 17,000
pound a minute so every minute they're
late that's 17,000 that does not go
through the tills of that large store so
I know that's their sales but that's the
sort of money that scale it right down
to the high street that Greg was talking
it all counts on it I know sorry I
sympathize is what they're saying I
people are attacking self a couple of
days off but I don't think the economics
of the high street will allow that alone
do you agree when we were kids I'm at
the right age say the shops closed at
five o'clock every single night the
surely closing Wednesday afternoon yeah
and it was in Sunday's where you used to
be with your family that I was the
sandwich shop they used to close for
lunch what do you remember the
legislation being passed me open from
10:00 to 6:00 can't they the lodge six
hours tend to fall there's a limit on
when they can sell alcohol as well as
there it's got to be up to the retailer
to decide whether to give his or his
staff a day off you know I don't think
that this is something the state should
necessarily impose on the retail sector
no and this should pay them properties
are gonna work it may be a
one-and-a-half times
yeah we'll have to double time they did
when they first bought Sunday opening
they did actually have a thing we say
you had to pay more but I don't if it
still exists doesn't good question I
don't think it does but you know you say
the whole thing about getting time off
in lieu never really worth it
you know you go to the opposite of
Christmas and they say we'll make it up
to you is that your parent saying we'll
make it up to you and they given your
brother a bigger rubber we've become a
24-hour consumer society have it for a
lot of families shopping is a social
thing to do I see them in the cat
industry what are you doing a boxing day
do you go shopping what do you do have a
family and I'm a Shopaholic and I yes
it's kind of the point because I mean
it's not just the people who work in
this or is the fact that us as consumers
and I'm regularly waking up at like well
I used to wake up at like 3:00 a.m. to
make sure I got to the next sales with
like five almost every you go to
football and a lot of people go to
football but what you don't want to do
is drive miles because the roads are
Kyle yeah on Boxing Day and the day
after
yeah what are you doing boxing is a
family event I think what you do in
boxing doing is that you just lie I mean
it's the wreckage of the Christmas meal
with all the wrapping paper and the
quality Street watching today I don't
think you use part of the last ten that
have been making turkey curry by the
killer turkey soup really good one you
would have to because that does sound
interesting when they were poor the
Johnsons turkey I'm sorry the amusement
has to end there